i'm monica
i'm jericho though jericho was already
done he's like
and i'm jericho she's like he can't send
yeah then this girl it looks like yes
yeah yeah we dated for three years maybe
like four or five months
yeah last week
okay you ready why did we break up is
that for me to answer
or yeah if i ask you the question then
stop
i told you this looks over
it the first minute this one
the first minute said his name is like
i'm jericho
why am i doing this
and that's the reason why y'all not
together no more stop
collaborate and listen he's about to
start ringing in her ears
we're not even relationship anymore you
cannot nag me why did we break up
you think i'm trash and i think you're
stupid so
god damn
man right there uh you think i'm trash
and i think you're stupid for it
we're breaking up why because i think
you're trash well you're stupid
bye i just got too
mad at you i think i was just mad at men
all of the criticism like at school with
your friends
and i felt like you didn't get it did
anybody in high school get it
they would to them and all that stuff no
we didn't
it's like it's a you know
but i you know she's also entitled to be
angry about it when she's dealing with
it
yeah which i understand i feel like
nobody really really gets a diabetic
i just felt like you were trying to
focus on yourself but then at the same
time
you kind of forgot about us oh man
rate me in bed how can i improve
i'll take a shot with you to not answer
that question
i'll try to deal with you you don't
answer
i don't answer we drink a shot we move
on
i'll say a nine okay why what about me
that's sad no it's not bad eight is not
bad
everybody wants to be a 10. not
everybody's at 10. but anyways
bro i was i was a five over a hot minute
[ __ ] i'm still at five i know
how to please my girl
yeah but yeah that's it that's a five
that's a five
yeah be proud with my five's at
there were times where i just felt like
you last a little longer
were you attracted to any of my friends
while we dated who who the [ __ ]
you didn't even bring me around your
friends so uh i actually like who
are we talking about uh yes okay but
that was it you didn't even
wow it's like i'm not even going out
with y'all and i want to break out with
y'all i would
i don't i want to break up with y'all
and i'm i don't even know you mom
i just can't it's just remember that
move that
that video that i said that that video
where you talk about what's your best
marriage advice
shut the [ __ ] up like you're making
everything at the everything is a thing
everything everything you can't
fight for about everything every lit
every little thing is a thing you know
what's funny
he's like she's like you wouldn't bring
me on my friends what the [ __ ]
and here they are arguing in front of
strangers imagine how she is yo
with people that you know love
damn yo you make me want to call x's i
broke up with and re-break up with them
just to make sure they know boundaries
hey what's up girl it's abba yeah uh-huh
you good yeah
oh yeah the reason i'm calling uh i just
want to make sure
do you know i dumped your ass yeah
just want to make sure thank you bye
[Music]
yeah why are you making my sound sus i
could do because it's sus
yeah yeah you know what else it says
sugary ass [ __ ] what else is that yeah
yeah yeah what's this yeah
i don't have to see nothing they know no
what's up they know what's up
yeah yeah yeah don't stare at me like us
tell me what's this come on say it
what's us what's up sabbah oh so i could
deal with you
you don't answer i don't answer we drink
a shot
we move on
every time
every time you say what's us he's like
what's us
and i'm like you
oh
oh man
what's the most annoying thing about me
oh god no ability to tell time or like
no i know i'm late i just like yeah so
you actively choose to be that
disrespectful
but is he wrong though people who are
purposefully late and they don't care
about your time
that's a disrespect my time matters the
fact that you think your time is more
valuable than mine
shows how you view me it's just how he
said it yeah
it's not that how he said it's like this
is messy
this is a whole ass man yeah yeah it's
like it's like [ __ ] you know
you know when you're carrying a tray of
food at the cafeteria
and you smell it in front of everyone
you're like and everyone's like
messy and you slide in it yeah
yeah yeah banana peel on the head
looking like a mario kart extra right
yeah hey don't you wish that moment i
was home alone oh yeah
oh yeah and you fall on the ground and
like i'm not hurt
it's not me falling down that hurts it's
everybody's seeing me i can't
yeah yeah it's like when you got a nip
slip at home it's just
yeah in front of everyone it's like oh
my god pepperoni
when did you realize it was over between
us
when i found out from my friends that
you're bringing some guys around
oh you mean my current boyfriend
yeah it was just hard just seeing it
with someone else
damn and like the like tone of the music
makes this whole awkward because i'm
like damn you just admitting like
when i found out you were cheating on me
and she's like you mean my current
boyfriend the guy i'm still with who's
clearly better
my current birthday net you know by the
way is at 10. do i ever pop into your
head when you're activating
i don't pervade a soul no
it's not something i need and when i do
need it i can get it
when you need it you can get it yeah
like
it's like it's like what's not being
said the way you went yeah oh yeah
oh yeah you can do it like that like
that yeah just get over me
yeah oh wow do i ever pop into your head
when you're
waiting i haven't done a lot of it
lately but
no wow are you thinking about somebody
else
you're not together you know what i
liked
preach when she was done reading what
she do
do you ever think about me when you're
debating
what the [ __ ] you did once she did
she was like so certain the whole pop
you know where that posture was like
that that yo
i'm just waiting for her to start like a
t-channel on youtube
because that was messy yeah that's
memory
am i a better lover than who you're
currently with be honest
the last person i was with yes am i
better than andre
i used to think you were
while you asked questions you do not
want the answer to
don't ask it if you can't handle it
you're here
that can't be asking all them questions
dumb dumb question like oh you're
you're here am i better than mine that
man you wanna you don't wanna hear
the question don't want to hear the
answer to the question
stop if you could erase every memory of
me would you
i would erase you making out with my
friend on the dance floor in front of me
because to me like
if i was like at a bar and looked over
and he was making out with one of my
friends
i just feel like it's like a respecting
like you know who you're going home
respecting and that's why respect levels
are but like i like expect you enough
not to do it
okay there you go well like i would
trust that it's just like a fun thing
you know like your turn
okay
no no i need to open a window
yo when things are not settled and over
and you try to talk about it and there's
a
there's like an imbalance in the
maturity of the people
the immaturity of the other person the
person is immature is triggering you and
the person
that's mature is triggering the other
person because okay yeah he thinks he's
better than me
what would it take for us to get back
together you would want to
and i would want to and we just have to
have a conversation
i mean i don't want to get back together
hey man this man disrespected you spat
in your face done it repeatedly whether
it's time kissing someone right in front
of you
and you're still open to the idea of
getting back together with someone who
doesn't
it's not that you just disrespect you
doesn't seem to be remorseful or care
you want to care you you you have some
culpability in that as well regardless
if he's engaging in trash behavior
you're also at fault for
wanting to be with somebody like you
have to ask yourself what is it in you
where you want to look for that kind of
behavior and see that as
something you want to build a
relationship on yeah you know what i'm
saying no
would you want to get back with me of
course i do
oh that was fast so what would it take
honestly the only thing it would take if
you moved away
and leaving your boyfriend
you can say that oh man i dare you to
post on facebook that we're
we're back together why are you posting
on facebook that you're engaged
is this like a joke no i'm so serious
i'm dead ass
dude my face is getting so hot right now
what do you mean your face is getting
hot how do you think i feel
well you were gonna be
her friends knows you trash
they know your temper they know how you
be hey
that's messed up
they know do you mind i know they know i
dare you to kiss me with
tongue take two shots to get out of it
i mean like there's some consent
involved what we can't do this
we can't do that because he's dating
someone
okay i respect your boyfriend so
does the peck i guess we can do that
okay
did you see that though did you see her
face
my face is similar when i i'm i i think
i'm gonna receive a smack in the face
it's someone you dated you know who else
is messy
the cut yo the cut is super messy they
know what the [ __ ] you doing
yo i know they're gonna rake in that
money but god damn this is messy
where do you see us in 10 years
i don't know maybe speaking
i don't know where you're gonna be but
i'm gonna be somewhere
i'll probably have maybe one kid
do you still love me yeah absolutely
yeah
i love it too before i saw you here
i thought i was in love with you but i
think that ship has sailed
when the ship sails the ship sails and
now the sails open the ship
sails and if you sell a ship
you get another ship with the money that
you race from sailing the ship
now be a ship your [ __ ]
can sell away sail away sail away
sail away sail away sail away
hot mess a hot one still a mess
bro it's been a while i've seen a video
with this much dysfunction
just awkward as hell um
anyways there's nothing to take out of
it it's just it is what it is
i think you know what's interesting
about it it's like we just watch it
we're seeing people who choose and
obviously
they're voluntarily choosing this but i
always think about the lives
and like how they're affected negatively
by all people who are going to get hate
messages
people who are going to get positive
praise people's relationships are going
to be
negatively impacted i'm just like people
i wonder if they have foresight before
they go on any of these shows do you
think they do
no they don't think it's going to be
that bad they never really think it's
going to be
that bad of a thing you know at some
point even doing what we
do at some point it was really affecting
me i stopped reading the comments
right about two years ago or something
like that now i'm good
you send me good i'm like okay yeah
heart sign whatever you don't send me
good if i got time i'll reply
but if i don't just move on but it's
just it takes
training it takes a lot you know yeah so
you know
death and [ __ ] like that and whatever
what not yeah
you know most people on the internet
will
act like they know you from one small
clip
they will do that yeah absolutely so
they will
just you know so me i'm used to with it
i'm used to it them it's a one time
thing i'm used to that
so they really think it's gonna be fun
oh it's gonna be interesting i'm gonna
learn a lot they don't think about
the fact that it's gonna be on the web
and the ramification of that
yeah you think aaron the vegan vegan
aaron
thought about the hate would receive
bruh
she didn't think about that that's just
the way she was just openly
rough she didn't think about that but
she got it she did
well that's it for today's video tell us
what you guys think in the comments
below
what did you guys like dislike or what
made you guys cringe at what point
do you guys check out today's video
[Music]
foreign